hey we'll call me meeting daughter
welcome you all here it's very loud
isn't it
can you turn them down you can you hear
that volume
that might be that's better i think and
i'll ask for apologies please
philip and john apology for leaving
early
apologies be accepted please a second
thank you just before we move on to uh
conflicts of interest in the
correspondence you'll note there's a
letter from
the kyboy district historical society
there's actually another one that came
today so i've included that in
today's correspondence as well
moving on item number two conflicts of
interest
no conflicts item number three
confirmation of the september minutes
somebody moved that these be um make you
sick and done
rent thank you brian at the same time
that was 3.1
we did 3.2 two different depth
and the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting on the 30th september somebody
made that they are correct to counter
that
meeting place
brent
those against carried any
matters arising from
the normal to a hierarchy
to a heavy community board meeting
no matters arising any matters arising
from the extraordinary meeting
no matter rising item number four there
are no deputations or
presentations item number five no agent
business
item number six reports update to the
community board standing orders
thank you to you
thank you madam chair this is an update
to align our boards standing orders with
that of what that was approved in the
council
earlier in october the main
[Music]
changes being made is to the audio
visual
part of the meetings this allows members
to attend via audiovisual link
and also it gives the mayor and the
executive chief executives as well of
the chairperson of the board
the right to call emergency meeting
that's basically
the only amendments
that that we have i'm happy to take any
questions that members might have
um there was a question raised by
philip via email about the composition
of
the code of conduct committee and if the
boards are going to use the same code of
conduct committee than that of the
council
it was discussed at previous boards and
at the mayor and the chairperson's
meeting
and it was agreed that that will be
determined on a case-to-case basis
once there is actually
a need to actually convene the code of
conduct committee
the board will via report make the
recommendation of who will actually
serve on that code of conduct committee
and then a decision will be made thank
you
get a second to please oh thank you
all those in favour those against
carried
6.2 applications for discretionary grant
and we have the kaipubara school
looking for 500 i think it was
hosting the annual back-to-back
back-to-school family picnic
and also the cowboy branch north
canterbury piney club
second up projects
thank you would you like to speak to
that jackie just that
i think it's great if we can support the
borough school in that way with the
family picnic
and give those parents a really good
time
the school obviously can't afford to put
on such things
and the pony club do a jolly good job so
i'd like to support that
thank you would you like to speak to
that brent
i agree with jackie kai poibara have
been doing a great job for their
community
and all support for their their back to
school family picnic
and the same for the the north carolina
pony club
again doing a lot of voluntary work so
well done we'd like to support that
thank you
and have a we often
have this debate around the table about
providing money for schools and while i
agree in principle we shouldn't be
giving money to schools for what the
ministry of ed should be providing
i do think the kaipabara school of the
back to school family picnic is a
totally different matter
and we need to support them
have a lot of trouble nowadays just
getting people on the pta
the same old
volunteer committees are very very hard
to get members for so
this is a really good cause allen would
you like to say
when i was a boy we didn't need enclosed
areas to learn to ride
this modern day
and may i say when we used to have our
little hind school
school picnics we didn't have bouncy
castles and face painting and
everything there but that's okay
thank you everybody 6.3 adoption of the
meeting schedule
somebody moved that maybe sleep a and
b well second to place
all those in favor those against
carried item number seven correspondence
you've all read the letter from the kite
from jane
jane turley regarding the misspelling of
wooten
which actually on the board spells
wooken
and i did take a photo today and sent it
all to you
um and there's also
another leisure with which i've
distributed this afternoon which
came um there wasn't time for it to go
into the
into the agenda and that is from
also from the kaibo district historical
society
asking if it's possible to get a name
on the riserly reserve
so can we have sorry you're moving that
way accepting i don't want to ask
questions
okay just of course if i can are we
still
naming reserves by signage or are we
doing it by street signage which
so we do
it's not actually the naming because
these things are already named it's
actually the signage
so these are general maintenance um this
request
via letter or correspondence is this a
maintenance issue or is it something we
need to get a report on to get done
chris i noticed the sign down there i'd
already sent through a photo
through the community board in relation
to the use of cedar and
already you can see that the letters are
becoming difficult to read because
cedar is so soft and it's been damaged
already
are you looking to try and repair it or
to replace it or do whatever
to sign down there
um a and this is an item
eight my report
and could i have a second to please
never no one's interested in second
thing tonight all those in favor
all those in favour those against
carried and if you've got any questions
please ask now
item number nine recommendation coyote
to heavy community board receives the
information and
9.1 to 9.15
you will have already received those
somebody move that please
jackie second down
yes it gets because it's an incommittee
report it gets posted
to the board members have you we don't
listen i don't
i haven't had anything posted
can i actually then can we just take
that one out and then i will make sure
that can you follow up with that and i
will follow up on that
thank you so 9.1 to 9.14
is the recommendation
you happy to meet that again nibble and
i'll
second that all those in favor
those against carrick members exchange
sorry
the district road and drainage
maintenance tenure evaluation and
contract award report
you must have because uh the value
investor has to go to the council for
that's actually the approval of the
contract the road and contract approval
that's right
it went to you on the first of september
a long time ago okay members exchange
information exchange i do have um
phillips here did he send it to
everybody
yes i did everybody okay
jackie i've been away
for some time over the last month so no
i all i can say is
i attended the sustainability
meeting the first meeting
and it looks really good
except there is no money but the whole
purpose of
this group is to
encourage sustainability in the council
you know everyone is on the staff and i
had to
laugh when i received this i thought oh
my god
sustainability yeah i don't know who put
this together and i don't want to
embarrass anyone but
um
thank you there's wee bit in the
environmental space um
pc7 hearings have started they're at
wigram
and they go over five weeks every other
week
and the council appears on november the
16th and i appear there too
and the legal advice that
ecan council has got for
the mps freshwater and the nes is that
p67 has to give effect
to the freshwater package so that
actually means quite significant
alteration
to pc7 itself which will mean massive
changes within this district
[Music]
the water zone committee ticked off
10 000 six dollars in the ims
that's the immediate steps fund for motu
kanuka which is a 13 hectare
patch of karnaka at airwell which
they're going
to a doc has bought it and
the immediate steps fund will go to weed
and pest control
this is really significant this is the
last decent
hunk of kanuka which is you know
remnant dry land of what we used to be
before we got irrigation
and they're trying to keep irrigation
away from it it's in the middle of a
dairy farm and luckily the person who
owned it
prior to selling it and fenced it off
and
kept it relatively intact apart from
a bulldozer track through the middle
which will eventually
regenerate um land and water
i've got you've turned me off haven't
you
i'm only just getting my stride um
land and water considered um a
big report on the kaiapoi river which
i suggest you have a look at none of
it's particularly good news
um but what we did ask one of the
recommendations was to ask ikean to put
all its fancy gear on the
um which i think you'd in indicated here
before
uh was to put all their stuff on the um
on the mandeville bridge to get
continuous monitoring for the next
couple of years um still waiting we
still get complaints about the cam from
mr bait
the weed dying or not not there and the
cam
and staff have gone out with them to
identify where there is weed not growing
and
as far as our work on the cam in stream
we're still waiting on the waimakariri
minor works and maintenance consent from
environment canterbury it's only been 18
months or even two years
um i one of the interesting thing that
it's come out of the
mps is that all natural wetlands in the
district have to be protected
and there is to be no drainage within
100 metres of them
ah that has quite a bit of effect really
um and you may look up blindside road
where there are probably natural
wetlands that have been
farmed and now
[Music]
not to have any drainage around them
um what else have we got um
i helped keep running europe beautiful
plant 76
trees around pond sea on flaxton road
um they're a good bunch they're all
about 9 000 years old
and they were there greg's not that hot
no that's right he isn't no
so um uh yes so if there's
now when you go past just just look to
your
left as you're heading up um towards
rangiora and you'll see these trees
they're quite
decent size you know sort of one and a
half
to two meters uh and i think that's
probably probably it at the moment there
might be something
exciting next time thank you any
questions
um
the main thing i've been working on this
month has been part of the walking and
cycling reference group
um spent many hours inspecting potential
routes and
talking to council staff and writing
writing that up
the group's been a guinea pig for a new
consultation package called bang the
table
which i think must come from australia
because it's actually quite user
friendly
it's not as aggressive as it sounds um
however i think it's pretty clear from
the work we've done so far
that a lot of our aspirations about you
know connectivity
are going to take a long time and
they're going to require things like the
wooden bypass
and a lot of the new developments to
have those cycling walking group
links in them before we're actually
going to achieve what we want to achieve
so
it is very much a long term plan but at
least we've made a decent start on it
thanks madam chair
now miki madam chair i've already sent
through my
member exchange report but i'll just add
to it um
in that i caught up with some of the
building industry
uh businesses here in kaiapoi over the
weekend and
the likes of kaiapoi aluminium is
reporting that okay they've already
closed off
all four orders about a month ago but
they are just
absolutely flat stick so the building
industry within
the district is looking extremely
positive however on the other side of it
we know a number of workers within the
hellers which are really really
good on reduced hours at the moment so
let's hope that everybody gets out and
buys some hellas meat at the moment
because
yeah this workers are doing it tough but
thank you
thank you so we'll let that go
the mixed business unit um the
subcommittee has
has met and assessed five prospective
um um invite five respected projects and
whittled it down to a short list of two
that still um under wraps with um
with um um secrecy but um
that by next month um i think we'll have
a report coming to the to the thing on
on the chosen one of the two well
possibly anyway but at least we're down
to two
pontoons you'll have seen our first
fully
full-fledged paying guest has arrived
and i've got to talk to
grant about whether he's in the right
place on the pontoon because he doesn't
know if he is and he wants to know how
he can start paying his rent and i said
i'll send him over like on his way home
from tonight's meeting
the car park underway you there's no
need to talk about that you've all
walked past it and seen it that's all
happening
um ian his i was talking to this morning
with the
um he can works at the macintosh's hole
he's just a bit
he was trying to get a committee to uh
meeting together of
councillors did he contact you guys they
can't do it anyway we haven't
we can't between us get the time that
suits everybody so he's abandoned that
um that meeting it was really only a um
consultation thing but we we he talked
about um
what we need to do and i said the
biggest thing is informing the fishermen
and we've decided amongst other things
he's decided
they'll put up signage when they start
which is the first week in december
and also the fish and game are going to
with the can are going to print
pamphlets out explaining the whole
timetable
for six months and um i said well i'm
sure
some of us can would if they give them
to us we'll distribute them
the odd time down there as well as fish
and game and he thought that was a
pretty good way of getting the message
across before
and so that we don't get a raft of upset
fishermen hammering on our doors
um what else that's oh dan and i on last
week went to
um naturi for a
well we thought we were going with
joanne and the roading
team well joanne start at the beginning
you will remember the um rooneunga asked
for a reduced speed limit through the
village and dan
and neville went to wellington to back
up that
and fought for it because they wanted it
down to 40 and nzta will normally not
give you a 40.
and this meeting was supposed to be
putting a map on the table and showing
them
what we'd achieved so far and about two
hours notice
um dan was told it was a full-blown hui
with a poffery
which we were not quite culturally
prepared for
but never mind and poor old tania tried
her very best to um
point out that we were here to discuss
the 40 um the 40k
speed limit but we got to discuss just
about everything since
tierra oprah came down and the state of
the cam and
and how it took seven years to get a
building permit from my house and
so it was an interesting morning but
good hospitality and a good morning tea
and they they have asked for the um the
40k
thing to be extended right from woody
road to basically the line road which
joanne
looked kind of startled about and has
gone away to think but
we pointed out to them their two major
problems are the rat run factor
which we do not control we can try
mitigating it but we can't actually
control it
and their other big problem is um
enforcement which is everyone
totally ignores their 40 sign they've
got or their 50 sign they've got already
and again it's not our problem so
they're they're
complaining to the wrong people we we
can't fix that problem for them
but anyway it was it was a robust
discussion
thank you neville thank you madam chair
um
i've attended many meetings that people
have been at plus the uh
you know particularly um sandra and elle
um but we passiondale
ceremony last week was well attended and
it was uh
it was actually probably one of the best
services i've been to
the speeches were of top-notch caliber
not sure whether we should postpone
anzac day and give everybody as much
time to prepare these speeches again
because it was a really
for an hour ceremony they were it was
really outstanding and i just
you know i thought it was well worth
being it so um
representing passenger um the the
working committee that i'm on
with passchendaele um and uh
of course the mayor gave a very good
speech that was uh it was well with uh
will was listening to so
um it was worth being there and it was
great uh greater christchurch
partnership uh there will be some
consultations coming up
uh which times will be
uh posted but i encourage you to go and
have a look at what the future
uh that people are talking about um for
the whole of
uh greater christchurch and the plans
that will come out so
we'll circulate those those dates when
they do come out
i've got 23rd 24th and 25th of
um november here but i'm not just not
quite sure
who's involved in those particular ones
so i did not give you those
dates until such time as we know exactly
what they are but it's it's consultation
that'll be worth going to so
what it's worth i think that you should
take notice of those
and just further to your comment about
the speeches i thought
um emma blackwell spoke brilliantly
spoke really really well from the heart
then so well
um and i thought i'd put it on my
on my own calendar but i say i admitted
it um the chairs and the deputy chairs
have a meeting with
mia um
every two or three months and at their
last one one of the
subjects that came up was a caricature
at the beginning of our meetings
and it'd be interesting to hear what
other people's thoughts are about that
i personally aren't keen on it if it's
we've got to do it i think it's
disrespectful if we do it
um feelings oh we've got to but
that's just my support let me know
sometimes it's not urgent at the moment
both me and dan and myself met with the
uh just
last week i think it was and uh she was
extremely excited to think that uh that
the council was even thinking of that
and that we
had actually gone to to them to see if
there was something that
we should shouldn't be doing or what and
indeed what it is so
from from that end um she's certainly
pleased to be able to help us out with
what it is that we
we need to do
so jackie and i are going up to um
healthy day at the par on the last
friday this month
so we'll have a chat to maraha and maybe
i mean my opinion is only one person's
opinion
we need the go-to from everybody
just let me know sometimes as i said
it's not urgent
sorry are there any media items that
you'd be keen on
i think we need dan to tell the world
how we've
given two of our local groups some money
the boat the new our first
yeah and maybe that's not going to
happen overnight dan
sorting out the the two letters from
kaiba district
society historical society that'd be
nice to acknowledge that
we've received those and that we're
going to act on those
please that'd be good
any other anything else that people want
to
put out there for the world to see just
in relation to those two
leaders we get from the historical
society a few months back we put out a
note
in the media uh requesting suggestions
for
road numbers has anything come back from
no way
you're aware no well i haven't have you
i will have to check with scott man yes
okay item number 15 i'd like to
move that the public be excluded from
the